oh la ketal aujourd'hui sur it's always
Monday c'est un petit jeu indé gratuit
qu'elle a un peu psychologique aussi
c'est l'histoire d'un mec qui est au
travail qui s'appelle Bob et il
travaille dans un bureau comme ça et
j'ai aucune info de plus donc on va
découvrir ensemble je croise des
explications mais j'ai pas d'infos ça
sert à rien des fois j'ai l'impression
que toute ma vie je dormais avec les
yeux à moitié ouvert un gros coup de
vent vous avez l'impression que quelque
chose a changé donc je crois que c'est
arrivé dans un bureau tout le temps tous
les jours et il a la même routine etc 5
étapes de plus et tu seras libre humaine
psychopathe qui aime ça je suis mon PC
je peux travailler ou aller sur
Chatroulette
comment ça va tu es toujours coincé dans
cet endroit de quoi tu parles
je suis en chaleur tu as toujours un
copain
ouais il a marqué autre chose il a
commencé à écrire tu as toujours un
copain puis il a arrêté il a marqué
oublie ça et la personne me répond Bob
je peux te voir agoniser je t'envoie un
fichier ouvre le si tu veux sortir de
cet endroit qu'est-ce que c'est ouh
attends
attends ça va trop vite entre nous oh
presque
[Musique]
c'est ce que je fais non non mais
j'appuie sur h il va me virer mais il va
me virer le con ça marche pas
je suis viré mais bien sûr que j'appuie
sur ah j'ai le tiens mon écran comme ça
il travaille monsieur [ __ ] 4 étapes et
tu seras libre on a fait une on a fait
une se faire prendre par son boss en
train de mater des photos de filles sur
tinder ne faites pas ça je vous jure que
ça a pas du tout vous amener la liberté
ça vous a donné que désormais ok allez
on va travailler oh [ __ ] il fait du
Excel oh non oh c'est oh c'est horrible
je peux éteindre le PC oh oui alors
qu'est-ce que j'ai à faire est-ce que
j'ai des poteaux est-ce que j'ai un
collègue bah oui j'ai un collègue qui
s'appelle Bob aussi on est tous Bob
c'est ça la blague en mode tous les
mêmes voilà c'est ça s'appelle tous Bob
tous les mêmes j'ai compris la métaphore
par la Bob 2 il a toujours des bonnes
idées Bob de kebab 2 kebab 2 ici
de papier dans la corbeille il arrive
très très bien Bob doute a une idée pour
moi amène-moi les burrystes qui sont à
la cuisine et je t'aiderai à t'échapper
et bien sûr Bob 2 lui paroles le boss il
dit rien comme au lycée qui c'est qui
prend c'est Bob c'est jamais Bob 2 where
ischen c'est très glauque cette boîte
très épurée mais très glauque en mode
les gens sont tous les mêmes quoi ils
font tous la même chose ils ont tous les
mêmes PC le même bureau la même gueule
alors c'est quoi les bureaux car c'est
ça oui alors j'étais burakas Bob 2 tu
vas m'aider à m'enfuir mon gars tiens
mon gars les burriculasses ah tu as une
clé pour moi comment
ça ouvre quoi ça ouvre un bureau secret
ah c'est ça regardez excite je peux
ouvrir le local
attends parce qu'on peut explorer on a
pas exploré un autre bureau mais Bob est
absent Bob est absent le patron il dit
rien mais mec il faut qu'on défonce le
patron qu'on aille le voir mec baume est
absent tu dis rien n'entre pas dans mon
bureau retour travailler esclave
il sait pas qui on est
du mois Bob elle est drôle ça va alors
où nous mène donc cette porte de sortie
ça la question dans un dans l'espace
fumeur c'est ça avec d'autres Bob open
the doors
oh [ __ ] ça agréable de travailler dans
cet endroit quand même attends on va
s'isoler sur le petit stylo attends
c'est génial alors c'est au travail on
va s'asseoir je suppose ouais on
s'assoit on va contempler ce merveilleux
arbres c'est très très beau avec cette
petite fleur qui tombe ah
transition 3 trucs de plus à faire et on
sera libre je pense qu'il faut casser
les couilles au patron à mon avis il
faut forcer auprès du patron et je me
demande ce qui va dire quand ils disent
qu'on sera libre qu'est-ce qu'ils
veulent dire mon gars c'est ça la
question je peux pas le défoncer il y a
pas moi je le défense tu pètes ce livre
sur son crâne chauve là ah imbécile
voilà je peux pas lui tirer la chaise
c'est la meilleure blague du monde en
fait j'aurais pas dû jouer à ce jeu
aujourd'hui je suis d'humeur à faire
n'importe quoi je joue un jeu très
poétique en plus on a déjà eu du
poétique avec Guardian
ah on peut s'asseoir et écrire c'est ça
on va faire un origami
ça part sur un avion ça
alors tu peux me permettre il a fait
quoi il a fait un poisson peut-être que
ça pourrait rendre quelqu'un heureux oh
il est mignon il est mignon Bob il y a
peut-être un mec qui a un origami son
bureau et je vais devoir deviner qui
c'est pour lui offrir ce merveilleux
poisson en feuille ah mais là regardez
il y a une pièce je n'ai pas eu bah
c'est elle c'est oh non son poisson est
mort
oh non ma pauvre est-ce que je peux me
trouver un poisson différent bah j'ai
exactement ce qu'il te faut il a des
petits poumons en papier en feuille à
petit carreaux tiens je te le mets là
ouais ça a marché 2 trucs à faire je
vais passionné mon gars par contre je
comprends toujours pas pourquoi il a pas
rejoint la fille du début mais bon c'est
Bob c'est Bob il est touchant c'est un
homme touchant ça même brave quand je le
sais je me dis que j'ai vraiment de la
chance d'être youtubeur [ __ ] qu'est-ce
que j'aimerais pas vous aider dans un
bureau comme il y a plein de gens qui le
font et sont très courageux bien plus
courageux que moi et qui fait mes vidéos
ah ici il y a des casiers sol
il y a un an dans les tiroirs non mais
ça fait de la musique donc je pense
qu'on va devoir trouver une partition
quelque part et faire de la zik
peut-être dans ce bureau là ah regardez
il y a un casier c'est fermé merde pour
trouver une clé do not open avec la clé
parfait on ouvre oh what the fuck mais
c'est glauque on est surveillé de ouf en
fait
oh merde
what the fuck oh tiens je l'ai giflé
c'est un réflexe naturel attends le mec
il a le mec il a un sixième sens du FDP
il sent quand quelqu'un touche aux
caméras qui espionne les gens d'accord
une étape de plus et tu seras libre ah
j'entends du vent
il y a plus il y a plus aucun Bob plus
aucun Bob what the fuck
mais non
il va se suicider comme si la liberté
finalement c'était de mettre fin à sa
vie mais non
je crois que c'est ça freedom
[Musique]
et B un jeu très qui fait réfléchir qui
fait bien réfléchir moi j'avoue dès que
j'ai eu mon bac je me suis consacré à
YouTube à plein temps donc je peux j'ai
pas connu un métier plus traditionnel je
sais pas moi caissier travailler dans un
fast food de trader un bureau être j'en
sais rien peu importe ton métier peu
importe ta vie tu es une routine qui
s'installe il faut juste savoir la
mouvementer un petit peu savoir trouver
quoi faire je sais pas avoir une passion
apparemment c'est le jeu vidéo il y en a
ça peut être la flûte j'en sais rien et
c'est ce qui te fait kiffer c'est ça à
quoi tu penses quoi tu fais ta petite
routine qui t'emmerde un peu tu penses
au truc cool que tu vas faire derrière
et tu arrives à passer au-delà et ben là
non le gars pour lui la liberté c'est se
suicider voilà c'est non ça c'est non ça
je dis non bref c'est encore un jeu qui
me fait me rendre compte à quel point
j'ai de la chance mais qu'il faut aussi
me rendre compte qu'il y a des gens qui
vivent ça qui qui se sentent très très
mal parce qu'ils ont une vie très qui se
répète une sale routine qui les fait
chier j'arrive pas à en sortir il y a
rien de nouveau rien l'effet kiffer
faites vous kiffer les gens j'en sais
rien aujourd'hui il y a 10000 moyens de
kiffer de se divertir d'apprendre des
choses surtout avec internet alors
foncez demain je veux ça jouer de la
flûte de ouf et qui me fasse un morceau
regardez n'hésitez pas à mettre un pouce
bleu j'aime bien j'aime bien j'aime bien
les petits jeux comme ça qu'il faut
réfléchir qui sont assez psychologique
et vous avez l'air des messages aussi
donc ça fait très plaisir ça prouve
finalement qu'on a grandi tous ensemble
qu'on mûrit c'est beau c'est vrai je
suis sûr que si vous avez fait ce jeu il
y a 4 ans les gens m'auraient pas kiffé
quoi et même moi j'aurais pas kiffé
alors la semaine prochaine regardez
portez-vous bien tiens tout le monde
[ __ ] il m'a flingué j'avais de
l'énergie je sortais des vannes et là il
m'a il me fait réfléchir de ouf le jeu
allez on finit tous la journée comme ça
sur son siège à très vite
c'est long
[Musique]